foreign
Elizabeth is with us in Dallas hi
Elizabeth welcome to the Ramsey Show
hello how are you great what's up
hi so I have a question I've been with
my partner and boyfriend for seven years
and we have two small children together
and I've recently brought up the fact
that we should get married and actually
have one bank account and do everything
together and he says that he doesn't
want to do that but marriage is not why
he doesn't want to do marriage he says
because he's already previously been
married and he's just not he's just not
going to do it why does he think he's
not married now
I'm not sure he's got all the he's got
everything he had to do with marriage
right now
so now my next question he gets sick he
gets sick he wants you to make him
chicken soup right
yes yeah what's the difference in this
in marriage I'm confused well
either accept him or
so Elizabeth I want you to hear what
he's actually telling you
he's telling you he went all in on
somebody once and got hurt or broke up
with or whatever
and he's looking at you after seven
years and two children and saying you're
not worth that
I'd rather
um have my illusion of singleness in my
back pocket at all times
so that I can preserve my little fragile
ego meanwhile Playhouse and play house
with you and you be my wife and I'll
keep all the equity and everything and
I'll keep all my money and I'll
basically pay you like a live-in nanny
um but this is all mine
that's what he's telling you
I hate that for you I'm sorry I hate
that for you
how old are your babies
um one is four and the first one little
boy little girl what
um it's a one-year-old boy and a
four-year-old girl
so at this point I'm at the point that I
don't know what to do I don't know if 20
years from now your daughter is 24 and
she asks you this question what do you
tell her
I don't know
[Music]
I'm not gonna
I'm not going to be the person that
tells you you got to stay or leave
because I don't want I don't want you to
hang on to this guy said this that's
something that's a decision you're gonna
have to own
what I will tell you is I think you are
worth going all in on
and I think you're worth having a home
that two people want to do life together
and create a safe space to raise these
two beautiful little babies
you're worth that
but you're gonna have to make the
grown-up decision on whether you stay
and you try to build a life inside of a
cocoon or
you make other decisions
in two weeks in two weeks I'll be go
ahead I'm sorry go ahead babe what
um I'm mostly more afraid of like if I
walk away how would I manage with money
I haven't worked in a while
so that's
I'm gonna be truthful that's exactly
what's stopping me now from walking away
and that's a very real fear I mean
that's a very real fear the the data
suggests that when men and women split
up especially in this situation his net
worth will actually go up and yours will
go down for a season
until you get so pissed off that you
become a multi-millionaire later but
yeah
um
but yeah the uh uh so in other words you
can't do this today it's Theory
because you got babies you have to feed
but you can say all right I'm gonna plan
my Escape
and I'm gonna get my career tooled up
and I'm gonna go get a job and I'm gonna
start making some serious money and then
I get to make decisions from strength
rather than from weakness
to walk to something not run from
something
and then you can walk in and go uh not
sure dude that I want to marry you so
there's that
and that's what we call an Elizabeth
burn right when you flip the whole thing
around
mic drop yeah but that comes from
strength and your yours your um
when you're scared and broke it keeps
you from making decisions so let's move
from scared and broke and then remake
the decision you might make the decision
under strength to stay but you would
need to make it from strength rather
than from weakness is that logical
yes so if it takes you a year to start
making forty thousand dollars a year
then take that year and go do it that's
fine I got no plan got no problem
and you're in Dallas he ain't going
nowhere yeah and you're in Dallas man
there will be people that will hire you
in about 20 seconds
I don't want my kids in daycare then
marry their mother hey Elizabeth it's
not uncommon in this situation
especially after this long
that this isn't the only thing that this
person won't quote unquote do
this person's been telling you that your
things you think are funny or stupid and
the feelings are concerns you have about
any number of things are dumb
you can't fill in the blank and after
seven years after almost a decade of
this you've come to believe that stuff
to be true right
I have my doubts yeah I don't I don't
either
because the girl that called here has
got more stuff inside of her than she
sounds like she does or thinks she does
now go get it
get you some
thank you yeah really I mean don't
forget two old guys believe in you yeah
and and uh and you got a four-year-old
daughter watching to see how mama is a
Warrior Princess
look out here comes Xena
you remember that one yeah but don't
make that little weird noise call thing
keep that one to yourself Elizabeth
don't let that only be in your head yeah
don't don't do that I'm gonna go with 32
years of broadcasting and experience and
go with my gut on something here I want
to continue that conversation
um from that last caller yeah the uh
Because the actual data is and those of
you that are old like me you don't
realize this data but more people now
live together
than are married okay
statistic I mean actual human beings are
more more shacking up cohabitating
whatever you want to call it then are
married
and
what people don't grasp is the data it's
been going on that's been going on since
the you know the The Love Shack of the
70s and from then on you know here we go
and uh so
what people don't realize is the um
unintended consequences legally
financially
uh relationally that builds up in these
situations there's
books of research on this now on the
actual results and in the financial
Arena as an example we'll start with
that one the there is a thing called the
marriage advantage
you've seen this data and the marriage
Advantage says uh that married people
live longer
I think that's because your wife drives
you crazy to go get a physical but I
don't know exactly what it is but
married people live longer and their net
worth is significant their net worth is
significantly larger and their incomes
and their career trajectory is
significantly higher statistically so
that's not like a Dave opinion
show you little farts on Tic Tac can
just go run off the cliff all right but
the the it with your little comments but
the facts are the data says that your
net worth your longevity and your uh uh
uh career track and income all are
improved with marriage it's called the
the research piece the buckets of
research are called the marriage
advantage in general there's a whole
volume also if you live together prior
to getting married
you are statistically four times more
likely to get a divorce later
I hadn't heard it being that high wow
that's wild you know and so you get and
there's all kinds of other things that
come in with the cohabitating Pro or I'm
going to try on these shoes to make sure
they fit before we buy them you know
kind of a thing right and so
um there's all kinds of data that shows
the disadvantages to that there's all
kinds of data that shows the
disadvantages to short engagements you
get you know you meet someone this
weekend and by next weekend you're
married statistically you're very
unlikely for that marriage to last as
compared to someone who has a six-month
engagement period average not a two year
or a six year but a six-month engagement
period average after the dating process
has begun because it takes a little
while to figure out is this a person I
want to spend the rest of my life with
duh met him at a bar on Saturday married
on Monday that's Las Vegas that's not
smart okay and so um just uh can it can
it work does it work occasionally sure
sure there's always statistical
anomalies but I'm talking about if
you're if you're 16 or you have a 16
year old what would you tell them the
best way for them to have their most
prosperous quality life is
have four or five Long Island Iced Teas
put all your money on red and find
somebody to marry before the weekend's
over right no one would say that
I would say that right no grandmother
ever told her her granddaughter that
right good grief no yeah just saddle up
at the daiquiri bar and see how this
works
if you marry ultimate the daiquiri bar
I'm just gonna go ahead and say that
study's probably not been done that
ain't gonna last Ain't Gonna Last that's
a John deloney study yes all right but
here's the other I don't know that this
study's been done and I don't know that
it needs to be
that last caller said something that's
important in this it's this illusion of
freedom and singleness
I'm gonna live with somebody for two
years five years seven years I'm gonna
have kids with them but I'm not gonna
get married
because I want to keep that Shard right
at the door one foot out the door and
what you forget is
he or she can't fully anchor into you
those kids can't fully anchor into this
unit
um
because it's not fully a unit yet
because you got one foot out of the boat
you only Row in one one armed right you
know it's so hard it's impossible and
it's put her in a position almost as if
she was in a domestic violence situation
she's not I don't think but um but but
she's trapped and that's the the abuser
uses the trapped oh you how you gonna
live you ain't gain money you know and
so they're trapped so they stay in the
punching bag scenario because that's the
only way the kids get to eat but also
guess what the kids get to watch this
and so they think that's how it's done
and this is a problem yeah it's a
serious problem so just telling you I
mean what would you tell
your
seven-year-old daughter right your your
17 year old daughter your 17 year old
son what is a man look like in these
situations well you know a a reasonable
length of Engagement
um not living together prior to marriage
and then getting married you have the oh
by the way if you graduate from college
you know you heard this thing 50 of the
marriages fail you heard that one yeah
it's absolutely not true that's right
absolutely not true they don't
okay if you make more than fifty
thousand dollars a year household income
both of you graduate from college and
both of your parents are still married
you have a 90 chance of your marriage
lasting
that's the stats that's the real stats
okay so this then some of these are you
can't control whether your parents are
still together but you can control
graduating from school you can control
accomplishing goals you can control
delaying pleasure called maturity you
can control these things these are
controllables that you can use to set
the table for your life
and then you get to see what the results
are what the what the fruit is out of
that and so you know so you know none of
my children prior to marriage live
together none of them it was it because
Dad's a big old meaning no it's because
autonomous stuff Tom you have a distinct
advantage
if you will have a reasonable length of
Engagement
graduate from school make a reasonable
income
marry someone that is of the same
religious preference that you are uh
learn to set boundaries with extended
family if you do all of these things
it's agree on kids how many to have and
whether let them live all these kinds of
things right and that was a joke and um
sort of you know the the um but I mean
when you have these things lined up
ahead of time your probability of having
a a marriage that lasts is very high I
mean Sharon I'm getting ready to
celebrate 41 years and there have been
times we almost killed each other but
you fell back on that Covenant well and
we fell back on this value system that
set us up to win
I mean it's just ridiculous I always
like to flip the coin and ask myself
what is it what has happened in this
many years and
for people to opt out and I I do want to
put some of the ownership on those of us
who are married with kids
if
you make marriage appear to be miserable
and you scream and you fight and you
it's abusive and somebody's always
leaving or coming or going
what kid in their right mind would look
and go I want to opt into that and so I
feel an an extra responsibility to model
for my kids here's what love looks like
here's what coming back together after
disagreement uh here's what the repairs
they call it here's that looks like
here's what's saying I'm sorry looks
like here's what's asking for
forgiveness looks like I want to model
this is the best way to to create a
world going forward and if you didn't
have that and you're entering into
marriage you need to get some people in
your life that you see do have 40 years
50 years ahead of you and they can give
you some wisdom along the way but
there's something about man this doesn't
have to be the old ball and chain as the
old songs go
this could be the greatest thing that
ever happened to you if you opt into it
and you live into it that way
well and all the data that I'm just
saying indicates that right is it
perfect no no that hillbilly woman I
about killed each other a couple times
oh man you know I'm just saying it's not
perfect I've almost set fire to my
marriage
yeah multiple but that but that doesn't
mean that we weren't dialed in and going
what do I want when I'm old really old
I'm old now but I mean really what what
do I want then that's real you know
that's real older than me that's really
up this is the Ramsay show